tim how are you man good to see you good
good to see you you doing well
i'm doing well happy saturday i
overheard you just saying that you do
not miss those wagons
but i'm going right back to them so
yeah
yeah we still got filming to do
i i'm imagining when you're out there
you know that
as a viewer it's amazing to see because
it looks
real it looks hard
right it looks hard what they're going
through but it also looks hard what
you're doing to get those characters to
that place how difficult is it a process
to actually live in those boots while
you're filming out there well you know
it's because of the environments that
we've been in
the weather we've been in the heat the
cold the wind all the things we've been
in it's it's pretty easy to imagine
yourself in those situations but the
difference is we get to take a break
we get to
cut go get lunch you know hang out in
our chairs for a little while to step
back into it but then you think about
the journey that that these people made
and how tough they had to be to make it
i i've told faith several times i think
that i would have been about a week and
i would have said you know honey this
looks like a pretty good place right
here
because you know those wagons aren't
comfortable and they're a lot smaller
than you think they are when you you
know when we first showed up on set and
saw the wagons they were like gosh these
things are so tiny because because you
have this vision of these wagons being
bigger but they're they're really tiny
and they're not comfortable and they're
they're hard to drive and we spend a lot
of time driving them i haven't driven
the wagon much faith drives the wagon a
lot but um yeah so i'm always i get
lucky i'm on the horse and not bouncing
around on the wagon all the time but but
uh it was it was a tough life and a
tough road and there are a lot of tough
i think even the animals were tougher
than i mean
the horses were tougher than i mean it
was it was a certainly a different breed
of people i think that that took those
journeys and it's certainly the ones
that made it
mm-hmm
yeah i looked at the opening scenes of
that first episode they went yeah no
that's
there's no way i would have made it i
would have been maybe that first guy
with the wagon that would have been me
just like what we've gotten i'm gone i'm
sure yeah
[Laughter]
so tell me how this came to be that you
and faith
get to do this together get to go on
this adventure together
wow you know it's
i we did i got a call from taylor
last year sometime last year gosh time
has sort of ran together over the last
two or three years as ever for everybody
but i got a call from taylor first my my
agent um from caa brian laps called me
and said that you know taylor sheridan
wants to call you he's alright if i give
him your number and of course i'm like
of course give taylor my number because
we were big yellowstone fans to start
with from the very first episode that it
came out and so i get a phone call and
it's taylor and he go you know he's said
are you a yellowstone fan do you want to
you know i'd like for you to be in the
show do an episode or something and i
said i'd love to but let's come up with
something that's really cool and
interesting and
if you come up with something cool and
interesting you know like i don't want
to be just a singing cowboy that gets
taken to the train station you know come
up with something cool and interesting
and and of course i'll be interested in
he came back and he came up with these
flashback sort of scenes um
with the original duttons who founded
yellowstone
and i thought that that was very
interesting and very cool and and an
interesting way to introduce me as a
character into that show
um and then he called back again he says
well you're gonna have a wife in this
you know see you think maybe
faith would be interested she did so we
did a few episodes um
and then
i guess
december last year
taylor called and said that you know the
the studio has seen the flashback stuff
and and they're
they want to do a whole series off of
this and are you guys interested and
and i was
certainly interested and then when we
started reading the scripts when he
started sending scripts that he had
written for this show
we were blown away and when faith and i
looked at each other and says you know
we we have to find a way to do this
because
you know whatever our schedule is
whatever
time we have
it's just so well written and so good
um the storytelling is so spectacular
and it's so
engaging and it's so tragic and
heartbreaking yeah and real all at the
same time i mean it's very rare that you
get a chance to do this individually
something this this good and this this
much quality and then super rare as
husband and wife to get to do it
together
yeah i mean if i could just gush about
her for a minute
well i mean she really embodies this
strength right like she's she is that
character she's in that role when you
guys are done filming a day
and you've gone through everything that
you've gone through are you reflecting
and going like whoa like
you really surprised me with that beat
or i'm really impressed with how you did
xyz
sometimes you know sometimes we're just
so exhausted that we just eat and go to
bed and go to sleep
but because it's long hours and
and you know it's hard work and
as you can see i mean as you when you
see it it's not just sort of walking
through scenes there's a lot of physical
stuff that goes on but then there's some
nights when you just magic happens and
you have magical scenes where everything
just flows and you almost forget about
it that's when you when you know you're
having really good scenes is when you do
the scene and you almost forget what you
just did because the scene was so good
and then those are the nights that we'll
sit up for a couple hours and talk about
it and talk about how much fun it is and
how excited we are to be able to do this
and and sort of feed off each other's
energy
yeah one thing that's a really nice
thread between both yellowstone and 1883
is that there are some very talented
musicians putting on some
spectacular acting in both of these
movies but i'm curious if if the role if
the the journey and the the difficulty
that you're imagining being in has
actually inspired any music
you know
i've written stuff along the way i mean
i'm actually working on a new album at
the same time that we're they're we're
filming this but um but i've written
stuff along the way for um in fact um
there's an episode coming up where um
um wade's character is singing to the
cattle so i wrote him a little lullaby
for the cattle for it that you'll hear
him sing later on but yeah i mean
there's all i mean for me i mean i could
walk down the street and there's some
sort of song i did that comes to my head
just and that's all about you know
observing life which is which is what
art's all about
right on well man it's i know there's
going to be another one of those shows
everyone's talking about i mean i think
just living in the world the last couple
years
people have been telling me oh watch
allison when you watch yellowstone and i
think this is going to be the next one
everyone's going to talk about 1883 man
good job
thank you i appreciate it